hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round one of the uh chess
olympiad that started yesterday sorry
about not posting any videos i attended
a wedding so that's why i i i was unable
to post anything i i could have posted a
video from the wedding but that would
just be weird i i'm sure you guys agree
uh so uh let's dive straight into it it
is uh david silva versus levon arunian
and it is one of the games that could
have great repercussions on the uh
further developments at the chess
olympiad uh since uh levon is playing of
course for the united states and the
united states are the favorites to win
uh the olympia but it's uh you know uh
that doesn't really matter all that much
it's uh not all that common for the for
the favorites to win
and uh especially with now uh with china
and the russian not playing uh pretty
much india is the only serious content
contender to the united states so
absolutely every every uh point and half
a point matters and that's um
why this game i believe could be very
very important uh but we're going to
discuss about the results um after we
check it out so it's david silva board
one for angola uh rapid and classical
champion uh versus uh levon aaron
of course who needs no further
introduction let's uh check out the game
and see what's it about so uh silva
opens with e4 we have c5 levon goes for
the uh sicilian defense knight f3 we
have d6 and the bishop to b5 with check
uh we have knight to d7 uh defending
against the canal attack the c3 and
knight
g to f6 and here uh as the four pawn is
attacked standard weight uh the the
place to develop the queen queen e2
defends the pawn and then you continue
playing but here we have bishop back to
d3 a weird looking move since you
already developed the bishop but it is
one of the uh one of the top played
moves here so nothing out of the
ordinary yet uh but now comes levon's
next move and that is knight the e5 here
uh g6 is the standard idea or e6 or a6
but not knight to e5 basically uh in top
level chess only maxine vashilograph
played this move twice and he played it
in 2018 against none other than levon
aaron solomon had this position with
white pieces against maxine one game he
lost one game uh he won in the in the
london chess classic um but in that game
bishop to e2 was played by levon in both
games however here we have knight
captures on e5 d characters on e5 and
now
there are a few games where bishop a2
was played but here we have bishop to c2
by david silva and it is now as of move
seven that we have a completely new game
so let's see how levon continues g6 he's
preparing to fiance to the dark square
bishop d3 as lavon now has very nice
control over the d4 square and bishop to
g7 uh we have bishop to e3
b6 and both players castle so castles
castles and now ponte h3 we have brush
up the a6 and not allowing the spawn to
move as the rook would hang so rook to
e1 and now queen to d6 developing the
queen connecting rooks and preparing to
bring the rooks into the game we have
knight to a3
and now rook 8 d8 we have queen to f3
also developing the queen connecting the
rooks and not knight to h5
with idea of shifting the bishop over to
b7 to claim this diagonal and then
execute f5 so here rook a to d1 bishop
to b7 and now bishop to b3 now stopping
f5 as the king is in g8 sullivan uh just
gets out of the way with king to h8 and
now queen to g4 again stopping f5
and uh here levon plays queen to c6 uh
now it's uh definitely a a good battery
having the queen and bishop placed like
this f5 can be played of course you will
not be checkmating the white
king since the queen is still covering
the g2 square but it is very unpleasant
yeah and uh although you don't have to
do this because the white can just play
bishop to d5 but levon being lavon
that's exactly what why he played it so
here we have bishop to d5 attacking
levon's queen and now comes rook
captures on d5 he gives up the exchange
to take out a very very strong piece
that is the light square bishop so he
captures and queen captures he now wins
the pawn and he opens up this diagonal
to be used for attacking purposes uh so
f3 uh closing this diagonal indefinitely
and now comes queen back to c6 here
again uh you could start rushing with um
with a move like point five then the
queen goes to a4 attacks the pawn and so
on uh but um
that pawn really doesn't uh
do all that much for you can never
capture it because of rook to a8 so that
that would be silly uh but okay here
levon instead goes queen to c6 first uh
now takes away the a4 square from the uh
from the white queen but now queen to c4
uh so what do you play here uh we have
uh
queen to d6 now uh and uh queen to a4 uh
we have queen back to b8 now putting uh
uh
the queen here you you are defending
this pawn so it's no longer an issue and
now comes pawn to b4 uh you can check
out like i said the interview with silva
after you check out this game uh he
uh says a lot so i don't want to spoil
um
too much but i will need your help with
uh one part of the interview as i cannot
understand what is being said uh i i've
tried many times so see captures on b4
we have queen captures on b4 and now
rook to e8 defending the e7 pawn as the
queen was attacking it and now pawn to
c4 just slowly but surely making
progress with knight to f6 by levon and
now comes knight to b5 and it's not easy
playing this with black as i'm sure you
guys agree uh knights to d7 and now pawn
to a4 we have pawn to a5 attacking the
queen but just queen to b1 and now uh
this b6 spawn will be a weakness for uh
for the rest of the game
and there really aren't all that many
weaknesses for uh levon's bishop prepare
to hold on to uh so king to g8 and now
bishop back to f2 opening up the e file
for the rook with bishop to c6 uh now
the queen and bishop are guarding that
queen and knight are guarding that b6
pawn and the queen to b3 uh we have
knights the c5 now attacking the queen
and uh david uh very gladly traits here
we have bishop count respawn captures
now both of these pawns will be
somewhat weak and the queen back to c2
that we have bishop back to d7 and rook
to b1 now preparing rook b3 and rook e
to b1 to double up on the b file uh rook
to c8 and now queen to d2 putting
pressure on the a5 phone so queen to b6
defending the pawn and now uh rook to b3
just doubling up on the b file we have
queen back to d8
and now rook e to b1 so not all that
much for lavon to do he just has to wait
and see what uh silva will come up with
we have rook to b8 and the queen to e3
now putting pressure on the c5 pawn uh
and uh it's not easy for uh levonte to
find them basically uh
rook the c8 defending the pawn uh you
have knight a7 attack the rook now both
of the rooks can enter the game you are
infiltrating this position and it's uh
it's gonna be very very uh difficult to
defend this position so levon doesn't
want to go into this he tries what he
tried what he always does best he he
complicates and he plays pawn to e4 and
we've reached the position from the
thumbnail
as now there are many threats in the
position you can see that if the bishop
somehow gets the d4 then uh silva might
lose the queen of course you first have
to eliminate the knight but it's not a
problem if silva makes a weird move
we're just gonna eliminate the knight
and play bishop to d4 yeah so
you have to be very careful here uh but
even with all that it's still not as
clear for example d captures on e4 and
now if rook captures on b5 you can play
eight captures and get a beautiful pass
pawn here and okay bishop d4 you you do
win the queen for example captures
captures b6 now comes c5 and uh black is
better here but uh it's very very hard
to say if you will actually be able to
win this uh so it's it's it's a very
tricky position uh but okay after e4 of
course silva does not uh blunder this he
plays queen captures and e4 gets the
queen out of this um dark square
diagonal immediately and now levon plays
pawn to e6 we have queen to f4 now
putting a whole lot of pressure on
black's position ideas like knights to
d6 opening up an attack on the rook and
on the f7 pawn and levon can basically
resign he has to play something uh well
uh there aren't all that many moves he
can play so here we have bishop to e8
guarding that f7 pawn preventing any any
discoveries and now king the h1 just
getting the king to a bit of a safer
square not having to worry about any
checks uh we have pawn to h5 and now
queen to d6 uh silva says i'm up the
exchange let's trade queens i'm gonna
win this end game uh but here levon
played bishop to f8 uh indy was in this
position on mu 41 that david silva and
lavon arunyan agreed to a draw
uh for uh for some reason and that is
why i mentioned do check out the
interview by silva after the game i will
put a link to it first thing you will
see uh he doesn't mention why they drew
the game but uh i could not understand
it if any of you guys can uh
you know figure out why uh what the
reason of the of the draw is uh feel
free to you know type in the comments
and i will pin it for everyone else to
see
uh but uh you know from what i've uh got
out of it is that he
says that he can still lose this uh i
mean it's levon and it's a team event so
even half a point for his team uh he he
is more than happy with a draw against
lavon arunian but you know if you guys
have time to check it out and you know
try and figure out everything that uh
that he said
uh but um
of course uh levon still has the bishop
fare he's down the exchange but uh
you of course don't expect uh to beat
levon uh
from this position but with uh with uh
you know some some nice moves it is it
is possible and you for example you just
trade queens queen captures rook
captures and you start bringing your
king into the game uh there isn't really
anything black can do everything is
nicely defended by white you just have
to march your king all the way to c2
move the knight and then win these two
pawns and that's pretty much it for
example bishop g7 we're going to play
king f2 uh for example bishop to e5 king
the e3 not all that much for for black
to do g5 knights the c3 you have to be
careful not the uh not the blunder the
a4 pawn and here okay uh if uh if bishop
captures on c3 rook captures and bishop
captures an a4 you do win this pawn but
then rook a3 attacks the bishop then you
win this one then this pawn falls then
the entire position just falls apart so
basically best would be something like
king g7 king d2 like we mentioned
bringing the king over to c2 bishop for
checking c2 and now h4 and now finally
rook to b7 you double up on the seventh
rank and then you go after these two
pawns there's really not all that much
black can do here rook a8 to defend the
pawn rook one to b6 now you're
threatening rook captures on e6 so king
the g6 rook to e7 now doubling up here
uh king to f6 we were going to play rook
b to b7 and now well uh this spawn
becomes weak at this pawn uh also
becomes a weak you can deliver a nice
check pick up the pawn uh so it's dead
loss for levon but like i said i'm
pretty sure that it is because it's a
team event uh that's why uh silva uh you
know uh agreed to a draw
uh so a tough break for for levon and
for the united states as their main
competitor india who has quite a few
teams india has six teams under in this
olympiad uh won all uh all of their
matches with a perfect score and uh
united states defeated angola with only
three and a half to half as this um you
know uh
you know uh a spectacular half point uh
was taken away from levon by david silva
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh like i said it could be
that this will have a lot to do with the
with the final standings of the olympiad
we'll see how it goes uh i would like to
wish a very happy birthday to mitkins uh
and i would like to thank joshua
figueroa lintag richard nickerson
allison silva uh and david kimura for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on the
olympiad uh make sure to suggest as many
games as possible uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day